now the Goldberg author of writing down
the bones and other works says if you're
not afraid of the voices inside of you
you will not fear the critics outside of
you so it's the first step in fearing
criticism of our work desensitizing
ourselves to it I mean should we put
something out there let the chips fall
where they may
get knocked down and get back up and
then strengthen that sort of what I call
criticism muscle so that doesn't hurt as
much each time I believe you know
everybody faces criticism and especially
more so the higher someone climbs in the
public's view so how do we get over that
hurdle I know so many brilliant people
that just are so locked in because of
the fear of criticism that they don't
put great work out there I've found over
many years of experience in working with
writers that the biggest mark of an
amateur is the inability to take
criticism now it's certainly
understandable why somebody would not
want to hear that criticism they have
put their heart and soul into that
script and in many ways what is in that
script is laying themselves bare for the
public and this is a scary thing and so
if somebody doesn't like your script
they don't like you
but that is not the way to become a very
writer you have to be able to listen to
criticism because I don't care how good
a writer you are you cannot write the
perfect script you have everybody has
weaknesses in their writing everybody
has weaknesses in a particular script so
the trick is if I'm going to improve
that script I have to be able to listen
to outside criticism now then the very
important thing comes into play which is
who is giving you that criticism right
most people are not capable of giving a
writer useful criticism either because
they do not have this
true tools or because they are to to
personally connect it to that writer
right if I give a family member my
script what kind of comments am I going
to get back right it's not going to be a
they're going to be afraid to be
negative and be they're not trained to
give me the kind of feedback that can
actually make a difference in my script
now this includes a lot of people that
you know in the executive suite that
that are going to be giving you feedback
on a script producers agents and so on
unfortunately a lot of them are not
trained to give a writer commentary that
can actually improve the script and a
lot of times they will give commentary
that is contradictory
they'll tell them to write to
fundamentally opposite things and the
writer cannot do them both right there
they're opposite so it's so important
that you not only be open to outside
criticism but that you're getting
criticism from people who know what
they're talking about because the only
criticism that actually works for you
that is not destructive is structural
criticism in other words looking at the
bones of the story and telling you what
is not working and I have found that
writers who get constructive criticism
structural criticism they love that
because it's not personal
it's about the craft and it's only the
craft that can make that script better
so that's the litmus test is is its
structural criticism absolutely
absolutely and unfortunately very few
people are able to give that kind of
structural prison this is also why I
always recommend two writers form writer
groups preferably with the best writers
you know because then you're going to be
talking the same language you're going
to be talking this structural language
because any writer has been writing for
any length of time and is really
concerned about improving their craft
they know this they know that it's all
about the structure and so when you are
in a writers group within getting
feedback from other writers you know
that you're getting the stuff that
really makes a difference under the
surface that the average audience member
the person cannot give
you